my next guest we're gonna be seeing a
lot of him he's got a couple new movies
coming out thirty 22 which comes out
next week a nice futuristic film about a
space and astronauts and the end of
times and then just in time for
Halloween in theaters and demand and
digital today trick starring Omar Epps
good to see you sir good to see you too
22 is out next month thirty right next
month I got the wrong date right here I
got Tuesday October 22nd so it's
November 22nd yeah okay Berg so that's a
Thanksgiving one and make it one that's
just in time for right now yeah
fantastic
good to see you sir good to be talked
about both of those films in a second um
because again trek is not about the last
three weeks of the Dallas Cowboys
correct Omar Epps no we've seen the film
I guess that's my way of getting into
what's going on with your team yeah you
know no excuses injuries aren't excuses
and look the first two we lost
okay but we can't lose it a Jets that's
just unacceptable while you knowing very
well of the trials and tribulations of
Jets and Jets fans being from the area
yeah in particular that's got to be a
particularly difficult thing for you to
handle not lose that game that's a bad
sign that's everybody's on the hot seat
for me but I think I want to see what
we're gonna do against the Eagles okay
aye aye
I like your team against the Eagles I
just for some reason I don't know what's
not clicking the fact that their
offensive lines been banged up is
something but the defense looks like
that they're they're not being able to
impose their will and I'm in the same
manner that they were able to do last
year down the stretch yeah and in the
first month of this year on the defense
we're not getting a pass rush which is a
problem and I think for me on offense
I think Kellen Moore has done well but
run the ball establish the run first
thing it's all over jasm attacks he's
doing too jazzy coming out and and I
think some of these DS kind of know his
playbook I'm calm
well you know what fantasy makes strange
bedfellows as you know I'm a Michigan
Wolverine by this this helmet right here
so very rarely will I look at Zeke
Elliott and say what the hell
they not feeding Zeke right but I have
him in fantasy and they do seem to just
go away from him early on in the games
as opposed to just giving it to him I I
was called a game in London last week I
knew Christian McCaffrey was getting it
everybody in London new Christian
McCaffrey hate everyone's who's
negotiating brexit new Christian because
and they handed him a federal in the
world 30 damn times they gave it to him
you know what touches touches they
finally did that with Zeke this week but
it still didn't come up with a win you
know did it they did it too late in the
game I mean the game was you playing a
different game when you're trying to
catch up right you know I just think
they need to get back to fundamentals
Garrett's on the hot seat once again
it's weird how the teams take on the
seem like that they take on the
personality of the coach yes and as a
human being
Jason Garrett's lovely nice guy but as a
football fan a cowboy friend I need my
team to have more grit you know and this
is not everybody's gotten paid and now
you're not playing I'm not feeling it
you don't mean Zeke got paid the people
in addy got paid Jack hasn't been paid
that hasn't been paid and he's he's kind
of his bag is getting a little lighter
now well I mean omar epps here in the
Rich Eisen show I hear you but when it
comes down to it Jack's got to stay
around right I mean yeah I mean right I
mean cuz you hear your choices with tech
your choices with DAC are to pay them
your choices with DAC are to do the Kurt
cousins thing which is franchise him and
keep on pushing out whether you want to
get long-term married with him or move
on and let him go and watch him try and
hook up with somebody else
and start from scratch by trying to get
as many draft picks it together as you
possibly can cuz you're not bad enough
to just on your own be able to draft
someone like two or Trevor Lawrence
right I think you they they sort of
built the offense around dak mm-hmm you
know you go out you get Amari you know
we got Gallup we got some other young
receivers and you know if this season
doesn't go the way that it should
I think I think they get rid of Gary and
you bring in a new head coach because we
got all the pieces we got too much
talent you know for and for me again
every team is gonna experience injuries
and NFL injuries aren't excuse Belichick
has showed you that don't matter
next man up so I feel the same way next
man up hey we just saw it here from all
the Steelers and uh and here in Los
Angeles over the weekend yeah a
quarterback from Sanford one Sunday
Night Football any given Sunday Devlin
Hodges
you know omar epps here on the Rich
Eisen showed you have Mike Dell to fo
the Steven a Smith soundbite when he
came here yesterday when I asked him why
he loves putting all these videos I anti
Cowboys videos up the moment that the
Cowboys have lost because he's a
Steelers in Giants fan okay well here
let's I he didn't say that but this is
never to cowboys it's just a fan I
really really really despise cowboys and
unfortunately I think that Cowboys fans
are the most disgusting nauseating fan
base in American history it's mean
growing up surrounded by cowboy fans
they never take any moment to smell
themselves when they stink and they
spent up the place it doesn't matter
after all a saree season they'll still
tell you they're gonna win a Super Bowl
that's why I can't stand that sounds
personal
he's wrong actually okay America the
most delusional sports fans on earth
okay or New York Knicks fans like let's
get this out of the way respect maybe
Cowboys fans okay you have a point there
you know what I can't dispute that as I
have sworn off the next Wow
I have sworn I'm I I went out the minute
Oakley was dragged out of Madison Square
Garden I was out I tapped out on that
spot right I wanted to tap out I just
couldn't but dumb I'm done I like until
they until the reign of error somehow
can somehow end but you do accept that
the Cowboys fans can't smell themselves
is that what you're saying
we're proud fence it's a proud franchise
with a storied history you know and I
mean all sports fans should love their
team how did you become a Cowboys fan
when I was a kid Tony Dorsett was my
favorite player okay in the NFL and so
um how was it and we're seeing you and
the training camp right here you lit up
you went up to Oxnard went up to Oxnard
okay had fun there's do you a tank right
yeah that's tank Laurens she's a very
big man no I I love this kid Jaylon
Smith for a story
he's just a great human yeah yeah and
those guys you know I think it's still
early in the season we came out the gate
pretty hot okay
you know we had a tough game in New
Orleans yet another tough one but you
can't lose it a Jets you just can't do
it now we got this division game against
Philly if the Jets is just the the Jets
is the thing you can't bring yourself to
just realize the Jets playing mean
National Football League to Omar they do
but they do they got they got a
quarterback let me know knock on this
one and overseas Jack Prescott that's a
fact it's a fact
Robbie Anderson's match better than
Michael Gallup I mean we could go down
the line here I don't think you want me
to know that that was a tough loss you
know yeah so now you are gonna root for
the nets as opposed to the Knicks is
that what you got you don't know cuz I'm
from Brooklyn you know we'll see they
got it we'll see kind of pretty decent
squad yeah I would agree with that
KD was soon as how great was that that
KD and Kyrie same day here we go
no one saw that coming nobody did mm-hmm
everything nobody saw that coming and
that's what I'm saying about the Knicks
fans like you think KD and Kyrie are
gonna play for the New York
knickerbockers and that is was
delusional it's like the Cowboys losing
to the Jets Wow it's yeah oh okay but
it's it's similar that's it but mocking
I don't know hold on a second Richard
Todd no no no no we can go on and on oh
yeah yeah oh there's there's a lot of
Defense back then there's a lot of
emotional scars that you see hit free
mimic run Yoho free McNeil was one of my
favorite players of all time Wesley
Wesley Walker I had it I had it I still
have somewhere I got a hunter that see
if it fits from camp Locanda I still
have my name stitched in the back so we
knew which bunk to return it to in the
laundry bag how is my jets my I had my
jets Wesley Walker Jersey I loved them
so much they would that was you know
Richard taja quarterback yeah I know
so you look at us right now see but I
was know what I just said sounds like it
was trawling but you understand it's
difficult for a Knicks fan to think that
somebody would go to the Nets because
nobody goes to the Nets Cowboys don't
lose to the Jets that was my biology
right there that is the same analogy
kinda sorta when it all comes down to it
though the Nets with Kevin Durant and
Kyrie Irving in that in that beautiful
Barclays Center Palace yet they could
put it together at some point and
actually they could they should rule New
York City for quite some time
absolutely absolutely and they should
really run these you know when you think
about mm-hmm the other teams I mean you
got Philly Boston maybe and then of
course there's Milwaukee with Yanis oh
yeah we on the way honest is a problem
by the way that's who all the Knick fans
think is next the honest is going to
come off they really think it's a real
thing oh it is a real thing yeah didn't
they didn't they the Bucks sign his
brother right did the Bucks on his
brother then they drafted his brother
yeah but now his brothers on the Lakers
I think Yanis is not coming to the
Knicks New York Knicks fans I think he
is that's all you got to get ready for
him stop dreaming get ready for Yanis
Yanis 2022 I think hey Dolan's gonna
hold on splits up let's talk about
speeds Etsy honest 2022 let's talk your
film
30:22 first up that's in November that's
a new him coming up what's that one
about it's a sci-fi film about a group
of astronauts who they they go to space
and something goes wrong on earth mm-hmm
and it's really it's really a lovely
film in it touches on these sort of
human questions we all have like you
know how did we get here why are we here
those type of things but it's a really
really good film Kate Walsh is in it
with me yeah and Miranda Cosgrove is
well pretty good for a nice cast right
there so did you have to learn anything
or do you have to go through actual
training for that sort of thing no you
go through any sort of weightlessness
for that so no no we kind of roughed it
we did a kind of old-school
special-effects okay that's good which
was it was intense but it was it was it
was a lot of fun okay yeah and then
pulled it off and then what's in
theaters today you put you played
detective Mike Denver in a film called
trick involving Halloween and all sorts
of nastiness that goes down one
particular night and begins to never go
away
he never go away it's a slasher noir
written and directed by Patrick Lussier
it was you know it was great to retain
with him we work together way back when
on Dracula 2000 and the film is about
this murder that happens on Halloween
and my characters is detective of this
China and then they it keeps happening
every Halloween and he's trying to track
down the killer and figure it out and he
sort of loses himself in doing that oh
and then there's a the scene that we
just showed in the clip like we just all
literally got scared you know what I
said when we saw it for the first time
and yeah we saw the film and we really
we really enjoyed it so congratulations
on that it's an honor man digital
digital today and theaters today Friday
October 18th we haven't done a start
bench carpet in a while
where we gave you three choices you have
to start when you have to bench one and
cut one are you ready for this okay
let's do that it's gonna get
increasingly more difficult each time we
give you one okay okay okay start bench
cut with all tomorrow apps if you could
only have one guy retire as a Dallas
Cowboy who would you pick jack
Zeke or Amari Cooper Amari Cooper so
you'd start him you had been show and
you would caught one you have to start
one you have to bench one you have to
cut one at this so you got your first
choice second choice and I'm starting
your story Zeke to retire your starting
account you have to have this is to
retire as a cowboy you know that you
know that that's that you have to start
one bench one and cut one so who's the
one that you want to most retire as a
Dallas Cowboy one of most retire it was
a Mario Mario all right and then your
second choice would be who Zeke or dak
mmm I Dec okay
then you'd cut Zeke he's out the door
see what I'm saying okay the game you
know what marry and kill right you four
that's the first batch okay here we go
start bench cut so you got to start one
bench going cut one fourth and goal to
win the Super Bowl who gets the ball am
it Zeke or Tony Dorsett you have to
start one [ __ ] one and cut one that's
good that's hard to win the Super Bowl
you got one yard who do you want you
have to start one bench one and cut one
all right I'm gonna start I want Emma to
run the ball okay so that's your start
right your second choice would be who
d'Orsay okay it seeks out the door
because he's out the door by the way you
have no problem with that what about
Darnell Jefferson you want to know oh my
gosh he's not he's not gonna get that
all right
you could pick one coach to lead the
team into Super Bowl who would it be
Jimmie Johnson Landry or Barry Switzer
Jimmy Johnson you start him right
okay then Landry okay what kind of you
want one did one Barry Switzer has won a
Super Bowl by the way yeah fact last one
who should be relieved of his duties the
most Jerry Jones as general manager
Jason Garrett is head coach or Kellen
Moore as offensive coordinator
stoic bench orkut jerry jones you want
him out the most as general manager
Jerry Jones okay then you bench Callum
war
okay okay okay there you go omar epps
right here on the Rich Eisen show good
to see you man please come back anytime
you got it thank you trick isn't enough
theaters today on demand and digital
today and then next month on November
22nd check out 30 22 watch this man in
space for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app